Olivia is with us in Lexington hi Olivia
how are you good how are you better than
I deserve what's up I just have a
question and I have a significant amount
of debt and I'm wanting to pay that off
but I'm also in recovery for two
addictions and part of that is going to
therapy so I use your regular income
planning sheet to budget and if I put
therapy at the end it's most likely not
gonna get paid and so I'm kind of scared
to quit that I'm not really sure where
to put it in the budget or how big of a
priority to make it how long you been
clean 75 days good for you well done
what is it
and the sex addiction and an eating
disorder okay all right
well no I'm not gonna put therapy on
hold right now this is something you
need you need some a counselor to walk
with you as you finish this life
transformation and that that is
essential to you having a life would you
agree with that statement
yeah now what I would do is this number
one it's not a permanent situation the
therapy is not permanent it's not going
to be there the rest of your life 50
years from now you're not gonna still be
going to that therapist okay I hope and
then otherwise therapist is not very
good but so at some point you'll you'll
pull back from that and the second thing
will happen is is that as you continue
to address your income and your outgo
you're gonna find ways to make more
income and as you have more emotional
healing you're gonna feel more energized
to make more income and so if this month
you don't pay any extra on the debt but
you'll pay your therapy good if next
month the same thing happens okay but by
this time next year we ought to be
making some more money right let's do
something let's kick our life in gear
and let's start to clean up the debt
mess too but for today 75 whole days
you've been clean mm-hmm that's a great
start right but it's not like you told
me you've been you know clean for two
years
by the time you clean for two years we
ought to be have different having a
different conversation about the money
would that make sense to you yeah so
let's get you healed and then let's see
your your money okay and as you go and
it's not gonna be as suddenly like a
switch flips and you go okay I'm okay
now got you the money now it's not like
all or nothing it's gonna be gradual
it'll be incremental you'll feel better
you'll you know when you're ninety days
or you're four months you ought to feel
different than you feel right now and
you ought to be able to do more and make
more and save more and cut more and you
know you'll have more focus on the money
because you'll be more healed and have
to spend less of your emotional energy
just coming through this right now your
game on just getting through this is
that right mm-hmm
okay well I want you to finish turning
the corner you've turned the corner
you're finished turn the corner and
let's go on out and then as you make
incremental progress move more and more
than money from your new income and your
increased income to the debt side but
for today we want to take care of Olivia
you need to be taken care of and you're
doing a good job taking care of yourself
proud of you this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh